hello and welcome to Boneshaker a small
family coaster with a steampunk theme
which I'll try to make in this hopefully
short series now I do realize that
Boneshaker is kind of an unusual name
and that steampunk is also very loosely
defined sort of subculture which not
everybody is entirely familiar with so I
do want to give a very quick though it's
probably going to end up being a quite
lengthy introduction to this coaster
basically I'm gonna try to go for a sort
of Victorian steampunk theme to the
coaster for two reasons
I think it's a really nice theme and I
also think it's a really good way to
make use of the new pieces and
availabilities if that is a good word to
use in alpha 2 which the first thing is
basically because I just love the sort
of general theme it's really got the
sort of 19th century Victorian
architecture in it it's definitely got a
lot of those ironworks and really
intricate details and ornaments on the
buildings it's kind of similar also in
that sense to Disney Main Street
buildings for instance have some really
Victorian touches on them and you really
see this kind of architecture in general
detailing a lot in movies and games
stuff like the Golden Compass I think it
really steampunk ish I feel Professor
Layton is somewhat steampunk as well
Bioshock is definitely very simple there
are lots of books even some bands and
things which have these sort of
subculture to them and it's also
something which can quite easily be
translated into buildings because it
really has that that Victorian sort of
architecture to it but still with a sort
of industrial gritty twists with lots of
gears and cogs and pipes which is what
the steampunk theme is most famous for I
think and sort of brassy colors so yeah
I really just want to go for it because
I think it it's a really interesting
theme and it looks nice but I also think
it works quite well with the pieces in
the game so far as you can see you can
actually make quite good use of the new
rotation system to get the windows in a
sort of really interesting arrangement
there to make the typical train station
round dome ish a glass roof which is
something that I've always sort of
wanted to try and fit really well with
the steampunk theme
link and it's really with the new
rotation system that I feel there's a
lot more flexibility in how you use
certain pieces and especially given with
the amount of detail that the Victorian
and steampunk ish buildings have and the
way that the detail was really made up
by a lot of iron work and glass and all
sorts of more industrial details I think
it's a good way to make use of the new
rotation system it's also quite nice
with the newest pieces like the arches
because even though there are obviously
classical arches I think they work quite
well for these sort of Victorian touch
that I'm trying to make with the
buildings and there's also some other
stuff like the pipes have gotten a sort
of change do they look like the entire
pipes are now black but you can make use
of a glitch in the game to actually
rotate even wall pieces and pillars to
any sort of direction you want with the
new rotation system so I can definitely
make good use of those pipes to make
some some of those like wall pipe works
you see in steampunk buildings and
things like that and it'll definitely be
interesting to see how the cogs and
gears can be made with all sorts of
different pieces which you'll see in the
future as well so yeah in general I
think it's just a really fun theme to
try and it should work pretty well with
the new stuff in alpha - not to mention
that for the coaster itself I kind of
want to make a sort of disney-esque
family coaster we kind of like the Seven
Dwarfs Mine Train nothing - really big
but still a coaster that really makes
use of the terraforming and a lot of
very heavy dense theming around the
coaster but still it is on quite a small
scale so I won't really entirely make
this a huge coaster or anything and it
won't be park it won't be part of the
park in general it'll just be one sort
of coaster as one little project that I
want to work on just to be able to test
this team and then sort of move on to
other projects or have other projects in
the background in the meantime which
just makes it easier to try different
themes and also makes it a bit easier on
my PC and the frame rate and all that
stuff that's actually talked about the
building for a little bit this was
actually one of my favorite parts and
one of the things that I was actually
really happy with finding out like
before I built this station and started
recording I just wanted to try a couple
of things and made like a few test
builds as I usually do of the theme to
see if it could actually work and it was
actually with that that I kind of got
used to the new rotation system which is
actually a major game changer as you can
see it's much easier to just place
objects and all sorts of rotations that
you want and make sure that they all
sort of neatly fit together so you can
pretty much nearly shape anything you
want and even though it takes a bit of
time I was actually really happy and
amazed to see how well this spire could
actually work out and I really just
wanted to have this sort of Victorian a
very Main Street ish
spire as the sort of main draw to the
building because obviously it is a
pretty small station but I do wanna get
like a lot of detail and some vertical
elements like a few towers and roofs in
there just to make it look a little bit
bigger and more interesting than just a
standard small train station it's also
going to be quite similar actually in
the way it looks to this Newlands
entrance train station and I'm it's also
a bit inspired by the city called the
mystic Manor in Hong Kong Disneyland and
just in general those sort of end of the
19th century Victorian homes and palaces
it really takes a lot of the inspiration
from that now I haven't talked about the
name of this coaster yet which is
actually quite a funny story or it's
actually terrible stories basically what
I did and I'm not entirely sure about
the name I think it's all rights but I
guess I've just thought about it for too
long and it's really hard to come up
with the name that you really really
love anyway but I actually spent hours
trying to come up with a name for this
thing because truth be told I am NOT
that's familiar with steampunk in
general it's just that these steampunk
that I'm going for because like I said
it is very loosely defined genre and
there are many different sort of
subcultures within the subculture of
steampunk so you also have like the
futuristic steampunk and Western
steampunk which is actually quite
popular
and I'm really going for that Victorian
end of the 19th century sort of
steampunk which also kind of makes sense
in a historical sense in that it was
like the period of time just after the
Industrial Revolution when people these
people found out that they could just
instantly replicate all sorts of details
and ironworks with the new steam
machinery which caused many of the
buildings around that time to be built
with a lot of details even the factories
just because people could with like all
of the steam machines that they had at
the time and I kind of wanted to get
that sort of name reflecting in the
coast as well so I went with Boneshaker
in the end after and this is the stupid
part of the name after I found like a
public domain book on the internet which
was written by someone at the beginning
of the 20th century which was like one
of these preserving the English for
future generations kind of books it was
literally just a book with slang of the
late 19th and early 20th century and I
figured it was a pretty nice way to get
some inspiration for a name of this
coaster but I didn't really find
anything I started ad set and went to a
for some really odd reason and there
wasn't really too much in the book that
I really liked and but I actually came
across the name Boneshaker and thought
it was really interesting actually you
might have heard of it before it
actually is the word or actually the
name I think of the first bicycle or one
of the first bicycles and it's called
Boneshaker because it just was such a
with bicycle then it shakes your bones I
guess it's one of these older bicycles
with a really funky design and like
wheels that aren't the same size and I
really figured it kind of fits the name
because it really is that sort of late
19th century contraption kind of iron
thing and it just felt like a fun name
for the coaster to have it also has that
sort of steampunk II feel to it because
it is like kind of an industrial object
and something that we don't actually use
anymore
which is also one of the ideas of
steampunk it's a really a mishmash of
all sorts of things but its kind of
futuristic and
antique at the same time because it's
really old and it throws a lot from the
older music in the order architecture in
order fashion well at the same time
having all sorts of machinery and
industry or sort of things in it I think
it's also often set to be placed in a
sort of alternate universe where we
still follow the sort of Victorian
fashion and architecture and everything
but yeah that is basically why I wanted
to go with this name I also wanted to
build that quick other dome over there
by the way which it's just one of those
other things which I'm really happy with
how it turned out and it's sort of
embarrassing that it's actually always
been possible like a figured it wasn't
really possible to build small domes and
spires on a one tile footprint before
but it's always been more or less
possible it's just been made a lot
easier with the new rotation system but
it's definitely something which I'm
really happy with how they turn out
especially they sort of clean look that
they have one of the most important
things I felt for myself that I wanted
to make sure with this building and this
team in general is to make sure that it
kind of looks clean by which I kind of
mean that everything doesn't just sort
of generally generally look what like
what it's supposed to be but it actually
convincingly looks like what it's
supposed to be and doesn't really remind
you of what it actually is or what it
should be so for instance I really
wanted to make sure that these spires
don't look like they're made out of
different roof pieces and just sort of
follow the general shape and design of a
real spire but actually look like
they're convincing spire pieces and
don't have any like weird odds and
sticking out and little sort of
unorganized parts that are just sort of
parts of these spires just because
they're built out of different pieces
like I want to try to make it as
convincing as possible that's also why I
kind of want to avoid things that aren't
possible in a really convincing way
though I can't always get it the exact
way I really want to especially with the
more industrial pieces because obviously
there aren't really any chimneys or gear
pieces or actual real pipes that are
meant to be pipes in the game at the
moment and definitely when it comes to
the Victorian iron
works there is nothing that even closely
resembles it a timid game so I kind of
just try to use the different pieces
like the balconies and the wooden things
to sort of create a general feel of that
sort of architecture and use the new
current black sort of framework which i
think is just supposed to hold up
billboards and things like that to at
least create the color and the overall
look and design of the gritty steampunk
Victorian architecture which is why I
did want to have that glass as a sort of
domed roof as well because it
automatically comes with that dark black
gritty color to it and why I wanted to
frame some parts of the building with
the iron frameworks even though it
doesn't really make that much sense I
just figured it would be a good way to
get that that black iron framework in
there and that goes for the fences
especially I do think it works quite
well for the fences like over here it is
still a pretty convincing sort of black
fence you just don't really get the
really Victorian ornaments in there and
all the intricate details and twirls and
stuff like that but it's somewhat close
I figure at least the most close thing
that we can possibly do at the moment
because there are no real small details
like that in the game at least as of yet
and when it comes to the back side of
the building I do not add a few things
like not leave it completely empty I
never really liked the entire approach
of the back of a building just being
able to ignore that because it's pretty
important especially in this case since
I do wanna have like heavy scenery
around the entire station and I'll just
make it a sort of separate station but
really make sure that you have paths
coming out on both sides and edit has
some interaction with the scenery around
it and it is going to be quite a heavily
themed ride in general in the end so I
don't want to completely ignore the the
back of the station but the front is
definitely the main sort of draw to it
and where I wanted to have the biggest
heaviest accents and hence also why I
wanted to have the two towers over there
which did turn out to be a little bit
too visually similar I guess to the
train station that is the entrance of
Disneyland which was actually something
that I only discovered afterwards I was
mainly going for a mystic Manor sort of
idea with the station with a central
tower right on top of the middle of the
station but I figured it wouldn't really
work with the dome because one of the
really tough parts to get right with the
dome over here and why you might see me
juggling with all of the different
pieces to get like pieces around it the
sort of dome the glass is that it's just
a very very narrow sort of window II
roof and I can't really sink any walls
into that because I know it'll look
really awkward from the interior of the
station so hence why it's also kind of
hard sometimes to add things around the
station Mariya the backside is used one
copy of the front sort of entrance arch
with a small roof with a little test
sort of dormer which I figured it will
it should be quite nice to use the bells
which are only possible if you really
have a wall to sink them into to get
some of those iron accents to at least
get a bit more of that industrial
steampunky feeling into the station
another thing actually which is you
might have noticed in this video is that
I got some new music I try to get new
music for every single series that I get
and try to sort of fit it with the theme
it is kind of hard to exactly do that
with steampunk since what mostly defines
steampunk music as a sub-genre is just
that it's part of these steampunk
community if you will and it has sort of
steampunk acts around it but I really
figured some of that other electro-swing
though mostly some really old sort of
turn of the 20th century kind of break
beats and trip-hop music is just what I
really like personally and works quite
well for the theme I think since it has
that mixture of the the old and the new
and that really well Industrial feeling
to it as well now I skipped a section of
the time I'm here or rather I forgot to
time-lapse that parts actually forgot to
record it so I'm sorry about that all I
did in that small section though was
just add some parts which turned out to
be a real hassle so maybe better that I
didn't record it because there was a lot
of trial and error to get them
the way I wanted them to and just add a
few rocks and some simple foliage and a
simple black fence around the coaster at
this point I also try to make a chimney
which will definitely come back at some
point in the future but not something
that I want to have around this part and
especially not something I want to have
around this station because this station
is more or less going to be a wienie as
you want to enter the at the ride and
definitely want to keep the station the
tallest building within its sort of
general surroundings to make that really
what draws your attention around here
and I figured one way to get some simple
scenery because every single thing that
I make I'm somehow gonna make somehow
gonna have to make all of the different
pieces into industrial looking things
and I figured a guess summer would
actually work quite well if that is
actually how you pronounce it over here
which is one of those like old gas
storage tanks which rise up and go down
during the day which they used to build
at the end of the 19th century I think
it also has a sort of factory look to it
and it's one more excuse to get some
pipelines and pipe works in general
machinery around this area and I
definitely do want to fill up the area
around the station a bit more but I'm
really gonna have to find out it's how
to give every single part of the ride
its own sort of useless contraption and
machinery
kind of look to it anyway that's about
it for the time lapse for today I do
have some real life shots or real time
shots I should say just to show it off a
little bit better than what you see in
the time-lapse this is basically what
the station looks like from the front
although not directly from the front it
it's just that I find I usually just
make buildings in a way that they're
meant to be viewed from one sort of
particular place not that they would
look bad from other places but generally
kind of build a building from one place
and that last shot was definitely sort
of the best here to view the building
from I think and what I sort of
intention intended it to be seen from
the front is definitely pretty important
to them where it really resembles the
Disneyland station quite a bit even
though it has all sorts of different
detail
and some different general shapes it
still has these sort of standing to
towers and the interior is really
similar to an old train station with all
of the pillars and the arches on the
roof and things like that
I might put some more scenery in there
actually and then the building from a
sort of top-down perspective basically
looks like this it's actually not that
big of a building and looks a bit larger
than it really is because of the force
perspective of being the being placed on
a hill but that's all just kind of parts
of the idea of the ride it's going to be
quite a small ride but I'll try to make
it look bit larger than it really should
anyway that is really about it for today
so thank you guys for watching and I
hope to see you guys next time